[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español la guerra en ucrania está por
cumplir un mes y con ella aumentan los
efectos directos e indirectos de la
tragedia en particular para la población
ucraniana primera víctima de la presión
rusa fuera del terreno geográfico donde
tiene lugar esta guerra sus
consecuencias económicas se dejan sentir
en todos los países para hablar de lo
que serán esas consecuencias para
américa latina saludamos aquí en
nuestros estudios al economista juan
carlos economista y profesor en comercio
internacional de la universidad de
surrey bienvenido juan a nuestros
estudios muchas gracias relación gracias
por acompañarnos en esta situación de
análisis vamos a tratar de analizar lo
que está pasando como resultado de este
conflicto que decimos cumple ya un mes
ucrania y rusia generalmente no son
grandes socios comerciales de américa
latina' pero el conflicto está afectando
ya a la región si efectivamente damos la
región por una cuestión sobre todo
geográfica histórica tiene pocas
relaciones comerciales y económicas
directas con los países involucrados
directamente en el conflicto que son
rusia y ucrania entonces los impactos
macroeconómicos directos son más
reducidos que por ahí en otras regiones
del mundo que tienen relaciones mucho
más profundas con esos países ahora eso
obviamente no quiere decir digamos esta
distancia geográfica permite cierto
resguardo pero los efectos de la crisis
tránsita envía el efecto que esta crisis
tiene en los mercados globales o sea hoy
ya podemos saber que esto es una crisis
global y hay diferentes niveles en los
cuales está afectando a los países de
américa latina creo que el primer nivel
es el siguiente venimos de una situación
de una fuerte recuperación de la
economía mundial en 2021 ya con fuertes
aumentos de precios de ciertas materias
primas agroalimentarias petróleo gas
ciertos metales y lo que está pasando
ahora digamos es una fuerte reducción de
la oferta de ciertas de esas materias
primas porque rusia y ucrania son
grandes jugadores productores mundiales
de trigo de aceite de girasol y de otras
materias e inclusive de petróleo y de
gas entonces en una situación es una ley
económica muy simple la demanda está
aumentando y si la oferta se reduce lo
que hace son los precios que aumentan
entonces lo que vemos hoy el efecto más
digamos que impacta más la economía
global no es tanto sobre la actividad
sino sobre los precios de esas materias
primas a este propósito con la economía
en general sufre un parón como
consecuencia de la vida en general pero
lo que se veía es que a partir del 2021
hubo una fuerte recuperación
notablemente de los intercambios entre
rusia y ucrania y los países de américa
latina en la proporción decíamos que
representa un poco generalmente del
comercio latinoamericano se puede decir
en este terreno que ya américa la tiene
es una especie de víctima colateral como
tal que el impacto más fuerte no pasa
tanto si viene una recuperación porque
algo que pasó en la crisis y el commit
fue que el comercio cayó mucho muy
rápidamente al principio de 2020 y se
recuperó muy rápidamente también y en
ese sentido también se recuperaron estas
relaciones pero de vuelta yo creo que el
impacto más importante pasa sobre el
impacto que tiene el conflicto en los
mercados globales no totalmente por
ejemplo al subir el precio de materias
primas como el trigo el
maíz y demás los países latinoamericanos
que son exportadores de esos bienes se
vienen se ven en un corto plazo
paradójicamente tal vez beneficiados
básicamente porque el precio aumenta
entonces quiere decir que el valor de
las exportaciones de esos países
aumentan entonces la capacidad de
televisa entonces como digamos
macroeconómica entre de forma agregada
región puede tener ciertos efectos
positivos por ese lado que varían
obviamente depende del perfil productivo
y exportador de cada país ahora otro
tema muy importante que venían también
habiendo presiones inflacionarias es el
tema de la suba de precio del petróleo
que obviamente estamos viendo mucha
volatilidad aún si bien el petróleo sino
fuertemente luego bajar porque todavía
mucha incertidumbre lo que sigue el
aumento el precio del petróleo va a
impactar también a la región de razón de
forma heterogénea totalmente hay dos
ayer ciertos productores muy grandes de
petróleo en la región como colombia en
brasil que son exportadores netos de
petróleo entonces esta suba de los
precios tiene efectos positivos para
esos países sabiendo que también verá si
le importa mucho
derivados al ver el impacto sobre las
divisas pues estudiamos ese medio y
otros una sola cosa otro país es
importante que otros países que son
mucho más dependientes de la importación
en el petróleo está suba de precios
tiene efectos muy importantes en
términos de la necesidad de divisas para
justamente poder sostener esta
recuperación económica que estábamos
viendo eso es creo que es el garante
digo ahora hay a sabiendas que a la
diferencia de europa el comercio entre
los países de américa latina con rusia
con ucrania no pasa por la importación
ni de gas ni de petróleo exactamente es
importante tenerlo en cuenta pensar que
en muchos casos entre rusia y ucrania y
américa latina son competidores en
ciertos mercados entonces al tener un
competidor por ejemplo el trigo un
problema de ambos personalmente puedes
beneficiarte de eso digamos pero lo que
importa es que los precios de materias
primas como el petróleo y demás son
globales son más o menos los mismos en
todo el mundo entre al ser bienes muy
homogéneos básicamente no importa mucho
el origen
como un auto
brasil es gran sorpresa es el principal
socio comercial de rusia notablemente
representan más o menos algo así como el
7 por ciento de su comercio en general
entre ambos los de todas las economías
de la región brasil expo importa mucha
maquinaria de rusia notablemente después
vienen ecuador muy atrás después viene
méxico muy atrás
estos países dado que rusia ahora se
encuentra bloqueada en su comercio podrá
piensa usted que podrán hacer circular a
hacer llegar colocar sus productos en
otros mercados precisamente dado este
contexto de incertidumbre que hay
actualmente pero no es eso cuando
hablamos de ciertas oportunidades que se
pueden generar
en este sentido tenemos un tracción
donde además los embargos y las acciones
que están tomando las grandes economías
mundiales como embargos a ciertos
productos suban como canadá por ejemplo
subieron los derechos de importación
etcétera hace que esos países se van a
tornar
hacia otros proveedores potenciales
probando y entonces ya hay ciertas
oportunidades de nuevas exportaciones
que se pueden generar para esos países
por otro lado en el caso particular de
brasil se habla por ejemplo de problemas
de aplicación de importaciones porque
ciertos productos no totalmente
fertilizantes que son importados de
rúsia
obviamente ahora por todas las
cuestiones logísticas
ligadas al conflicto ahí va a ser mucho
más difícil de poder poder importar esos
productos entonces un desafío también
pero de vuelta es como más localizado en
ciertos sectores de la economía a nivel
de agregadores el problema no es tan
grande porque digamos de vuelta si bien
brasil exporta rusia es una parte de
amoles y les porta casi 200 millones mil
millones de dólares si éstos las
exportaciones a rusia son de 5 mil
millones a que es algo relativamente
pequeño como para el resto de américa
latina también comentaba usted creo que
es importante destacarlo efectivamente
está en todas las bocas el tema de la
inflación pero en qué momento se podría
saber sabiendo que estamos en una
situación de incertidumbre completas
pero cuáles serían los parámetros para
permitir que la población se dé cuenta
que los decidores los que deciden
políticamente las políticas económicas
digan entramos efectivamente en un
periodo de fuerte inflación vamos a
entrar en un período de gran inflación
de mayor tensión es un trimestre dos
trimestres hay muchas variables yo
entiendo que pueden jugar pero como
economista cuáles podrían ser algunos
elementos que ayuden a descifrar esta
compleja
salvo algunas excepciones y paredes para
la gente de ambos temas en general salvo
el equipo de argentina venezuela la
inflación ha estado muy bien controlada
en la región en las últimas décadas una
gran crisis de inflación de los años 80
y después de eso hubo muchas reformas en
países que lograron estabilizar la
inflación que no sea muy alto y sobre
todo estable entonces volvemos a tener
inflación ahora en 2021 esta inflación
está muy relacionada con lo que
estábamos hablando al principio que
mucho de lo que está determinando esta
inflación que vimos el año pasado tiene
que ver con los precios de los alimentos
y los precios de la energía que con esta
nueva dejamos recuperar sobre economía
sube la demanda básicamente y hay además
problemas todavía privados al transporte
de bienes y demás que son heredados de
la pandemia entonces de alguna manera
esta crisis viene como es como llovido
sobre mojado como decimos argentina
viene como a poner más presión en la
situación que ya era delicada y los
bancos centrales de américa latina ya lo
reconocían con un problema de hecho que
hace los bancos centrales cuando
inflación suben las tasas de interés no
sólo para el mundo
anclarlo eventualmente eso permite más
que nada cuando más altos son las tasas
de interés la gente consume menos y
menos es como enfriar un poco la
economía
exactamente entonces ese es el atípico y
eso ya se empezó a hacer en el pasado en
varios bancos centrales de américa
latina thomas que ya se empezó a
reconocer que este problema y además con
la historia inflación que queda un poco
en el pasado por eso siempre queda en la
cabeza de la gente por ello los bancos
centrales de américa detiene a
reaccionar más ahora estas fuerzas
presiones
han estados y se manifiesta muy
fuertemente en eeuu también entonces el
banco central americano que la reserva
federal ya anunció que va a empezar a
hacer una política monetaria más dura
como llamamos que subir las tasas de
interés también entonces hay un
reconocimiento
veamos todo tiene que ver como bien
decía al principio con la incertidumbre
no sabemos cuánto tiempo de ver este
conflicto si digamos si es un conflicto
que dura un mes más y después volvemos a
la normalidad
escenario que poco probable no habría
tanta necesidad consecuencias pero si
esto se instala esto va también generar
expectativas de inflación que
básicamente que las firmas y las
personas van a empezar pensar que haya
más inflación en el futuro y van
entonces a posicionarse en estrategias
digamos relacionadas con eso por ejemplo
las empresas suben los precios y demás
porque una cosa muy importante es que la
energía primero que pesa directamente en
la inflación porque nosotros usamos
electricidad gas en los hogares también
afecta a otros bienes como el transporte
pero además son bienes que son
los que seamos insumos básicos dilatan
al principio la cadena de producción
necesitamos petróleo para hacer mutis
para producir casi todos los bienes
entonces hay efectos de encadenamiento
que suben los costos a propósito al
desencadenamiento además de su trabajo
como el economista usted estuve en un
momento dado asesorando silvio como
asesora al gobierno de argentina para
las políticas con respecto al mercosur
sabemos que el mercosur este proyecto
compuesto por argentina brasil uruguay y
paraguay había llegado a un acuerdo
comercial con la unión europea acuerdo
que no ha sido ratificado al mismo
tiempo el mercosur buscó un acuerdo con
rusia y los países de las repúblicas
soviéticas uno de los efectos podría ser
que justamente ahora la unión europea
finalmente se decida a firmar el acuerdo
sería una especie de derivación de este
conflicto eventualmente es posible
digamos una época en el mercosur así
unos años en que se buscaba activamente
y crear acuerdos comerciales con grandes
zonas y dentro de eso se firmó como
decir con rusa también hubo cierto
memorando de entendimiento y se firmó en
2019 este acuerdo un acuerdo en
principio entre la unión europea y el
mercosur hay que recordar darles que
este acuerdo fue negociado durante 20
años exactamente o sea que es
institucionalmente muy complicado y
luego de ser ratificado por los
parlamentos
es posible que digamos creo que también
vuelve a la pregunta inicial de bueno
cómo se va a reconfigurar el mundo luego
este conflicto todavía es un poco
temprano para saber cómo cuál va a ser
el tratamiento pero es posible que
digamos en europa haya cierta conciencia
de que hay que diversificar o que hay
que integrarse más con otros con otros
países sabiendo que el comercio
internacional está muy ligado a la
geopolítica eso sin duda pues estamos ya
llegando al final de esta escala de
parís no me queda agradecerles sino a
juan carlos y su presencia porque usted
es economista especialista en temas de
conversión exterior gracias por habernos
acompañado en esta emisión a ustedes les
damos una nueva cita aquí la próxima
semana en otra escala en parís
[Música]